oh yes the man of the moment is here on
Sky News congratulations thank you
hi Felix four heads just everywhere
it's just crazy just a whirlwind since
I've finished and uh yeah I don't think
you'll sink in to actually get home and
close that front door and sit on the
sofa and actually reflect on it a bit
taught me through the last few weeks
why it was just so intense at all you
know every day there's something
happening in the race is you know
crashes and punches and you know that
the fans and all the media and it's just
one big circus on the road really and so
yeah it goes so quick but it also seems
to take forever at the same time but
yeah it was just an amazing three weeks
for myself that couldn't have gone any
better when in two mountain stages back
to back and winning up abdu eyes which
is probably the most iconic climbing in
cycling so and then to keep the jersey
then all the way through to Paris was
just insane yeah crazy when did you
start to believe obviously after my
second when I knew I was obviously in
good shape but it was the first time I'd
raced over three weeks for the win so it
was a bit of an unknown and I just
didn't really think about it I just sort
of thought about each day as it came and
yeah I wasn't until maybe the night
before the time trial on the very last
day and I was like well this could
actually happen so yeah it was just an
incredible feeling I think you know once
that time trial is finished there was
just like the emotion just all came then
it kind of like let you guard down
almost you know and really soak it up
and it was just amazing and my wife was
there at the finish as well I didn't
know she was coming
and yeah it was a it was amazing
you gave us a bit we were having kittens
when you had that wobble on the time
trial what happened because I mean you
have been known to crash yeah it was
obviously a pair of wet roads and I was
feeling good and I was just pushing a
little too hard
I guess and and I Nico the director in
the car behind you just told me
settle down just don't push too hard
just make sure you stay upright and get
around in one piece because I was excuse
me I was two minutes in front of Tom
Newman who was second at the time and
yeah he was just like just make sure you
get around this stage and don't don't
worry about the stage we're in just win
the Tour de France and that yeah that's
what I did
you've taken part in the rest many times
before but you've always been the
bridesmaid rather than the bride haven't
you I think it's fair to say that Chris
Froome you've been his wingman and and
suddenly he's there for you how did that
conversation go far it was crazy really
it's just sort of he was the leader
going into the race I was a backup
leader and at the end of the day they
just the road decides as you say you
know somebody you know was always gonna
be the stronger and it's just gonna show
and the last mountaintop finish through
me lost maybe four to five seconds and
that's when it was kind of like okay
it's all four for me now
I'm ba it could have been awkward it
could have been tension but there wasn't
any at all
you know Froome he was so good about it
nothing really had to be said he was
gonna everyone knew you know after his
bad day that yeah he was too far behind
to win though and I had the best chance
sir it was just supporting me and he was
genuinely happy for me and yeah it was
just really good he's had to deal with a
lot of stress know her husband a and you
know there's been a lot that the French
crowds have not been particularly kind
to him
has he dealt with that and you think
that impacted on his performance at all
I think it it must affect him in some
way but he didn't show it I think that's
the biggest strength of his I thinking
the most impressive thing about through
me is the way his mental strength and
how he deals with all adversities and
things like that and it doesn't really
affect him and motivates him more and
yeah so really admire him for that he's
not here where is he how he's expecting
his second child today any moment now
so Michele his wife was was hanging on
the last few days I think just
for him to finish the tour and yeah guys
expected any moment and what sort of
advice did he give you about the Shawn
Solis day and driving a ride him down
the shore Solis say together through the
finishing line and then up on the podium
because it must all be a blur
yeah yeah he said just to try to soak it
up take it all in and yeah he said like
this life for me will change now and he
said just yeah try to have a good team
around me almost to prioritize things
and yeah not lose sort of you know just
just go bonkers so I tried to just went
a bit bonkers last night Wow
yeah the two I didn't do myself any
favors really so oh we got in about five
yeah like my head now I'm just
struggling to think of the string
sentences together yeah it's always a
good thing for a hangover I'm told when
you were looking out and you would think
what was going through your mind when
you were looking out at that sea of
people did it take you back so when you
first started with your you know your
second hand bike your mountain bike was
it a wolf yeah yeah yeah it was a it's
crazy to think that there then and now
you know when I think back to just
learning to ride a bike down the lane
down the back of our house and uh yeah
I'm racing around the park on a mountain
bike and suddenly I'm racing in the tour
winning the Tour it's just insane you
know running home from school to watch
the end of the Tour de France and now
and then seeing you know that the yellow
jersey growing and shaking the the VIPs
hands on the stage and whatever and then
I'm the one doing that this stuff for
dreams talk to us about when you first
realize that cycling was for you because
you had this secondhand mountain bike
and apparently one of the first races
you did you got so lost and it was so
tied when you got home that you had to
press the bell with your forehead
Christian you just didn't have the
energy in your arms right may be
exaggerated a little bit
yeah but um no yeah this is I think the
hardest the most I've ever suffered
divided the tour the first time it was
back in 2007 I was 21 and the youngest
rider in the race and I just suffered
every day and
yeah there was times then like it
couldn't even be bothered walking down
the corridor to go to massage you know
it was just everything was an effort so
yeah he just need just think back to
those times and this then I realize I'm
actually suffering that bad now and the
transition from being a track cyclist to
being on the road how difficult did you
find that it's tough when you're going
between the two like in the same sort of
year so like when you're attracted when
you're preparing for like the Olympics a
you know on the track in the winter and
then you come and do a road race and
it's that's a big difference thank you
like the endurance and you know you have
the explosive power and you can go for
four minutes super fast but then to go
for four hours it's been more of a
challenge but once I left the track
after the London Olympics each year has
been a nice steady progression and yeah
it's insane really how start hitting how
having won the Tour still just crazy
what's next
Wow get some sleep of thinking first but
yeah I think I go to Belgium tomorrow
actually we've got a race there it's
only like an hour so it's not too bad
and yeah not sure what my next race for
the team will be but I think just enjoy
this now go back to Cardiff and
celebrate with some family and friends
it's given Team Sky quite challenge I
haven't yeah I mean who's that who's the
leader I don't know yeah I think could
be interesting talks when when it comes
to planning the season next year and you
know obviously I have my ambitions and
through me as his obviously as well so
we'll see how it works but if you're the
same thing happen next year I'd be happy
with that but I think yeah well secrecy
what's your advice to young people who
were watching you this afternoon and
they think I'm gonna go out on my bike
and I'm gonna ride around the park
I can't do it it's a you know if you
have a dream just just go after it just
just believe in it and you're gonna get
setbacks along the way but stay positive
and keep working hard and you work hard
and you always you know you commit and
dedicate yourself to something good
things will happen in the end and yeah
just go for it what did your wife say
when you were four you can believe it
she was a same as me I think we both
sort of had that same attitude of not
thinking about the end not thinking
about winning and then suddenly it
happens and it's just like wow and yeah
yeah it's crazy
you do know you've won don't you it has
it hasn't heard Isis just this bonkers
congratulation thank you huge huge
congratulations we're so proud of you
here as guy thank you thanks a lot Wow
seizing thank you that was the truth